upstairs our goal is to help beatrice
builder build a sand castle i like this
board
sturdy yeah glad to approve now who's
got an idea huh we do
oh
mr prim and scatter good
first we need something to help us build
the sand castle and we believe that
something should be sandwiches uh yours
is better cool tools tools okay then
tools would be great yeah would be great
so that's job one get tools to build a
sand castle all right uh anything else
we need send ah
job to
get sand all right and uh so if we have
tools and we have sand then job three is
build a sand castle yeah
beatrice
we have our plan
we've got the plan got the plan we
figured it out we've got the plan what
happens when we've got the plan we give
a happy shout just cause we can't
cody beatrice scatter and i have tools
for the sand castle
follow me follow me
keep following keep following keep
following and followed scatter the tools
we have assembled oh they're all in this
bucket yes great there's a ruler
yes
there's a
wrench and a pencil
not the tool you used to drop how can
those tools help beatrice build a sand
castle huh oh
goodness cody is right these tools don't
help at all
we need to think of something that will
help shape the sand into a castle
hmm
wait a minute pocket
bucket of sand
sand castle
pocket
what is happening
he's getting an idea
we can fill the bucket with sand then
flip the bucket over that is a great
idea mr prim but can i get another
bucket that looks a little different oh
yeah because that way parts of the
castle can look a little different
exactly okay so how about the rule is
if a bucket is a different shape than
this bucket then that is a bucket we
want huh yeah okay uh oh here got one
this appears to be the same shape and it
has not the bucket we want
oh
here's one
it's a different shape
then that's a bucket we want
get tools to make a sand castle
check one job done two more to go
good news come with me come on
so uh
where is this sandbox huh
right here oh
oh
okay i see what happened here yeah heart
we need a box with enough sand to build
a sand castle you know like something
like a sandbox you see on a playground
with lots of sand
oh
wait here hmm
do you like it it's perfect
get sand
dick
one sand castle coming up oh yes
fill the bucket
no
sand isn't sticking together i'll never
be able to build anything with sand whoa
whoa whoa don't you give up beatrice
baby relax have a drink of water oh i
have water
oh
sorry beatrice i got your sand all wet
yeah yeah yeah yes but look now that
it's wet it's sticking together
i bet that'll work with the bucket
beatrice try making a sand castle now
just fill the bucket
yeah
pat it down real good and
now that's something yeah
yes sir
fill the bucket with sand
pat it down real good again
and
[Music]
[Applause]
okay okay one more
oh
okay let me just make a few final
touches all right and
done
wow
that is a castle made of sand wait one
last thing
build a sand castle
check
all the jobs are done um
[Music]
you